dot files set up or restore a fully
customized development environment by
maintaining a repository of text-based
config files
as developers were trained to write dry
code do not repeat yourself
but this principle also applies to other
areas of a developer's life like the
configuration of a development
environment
imagine this you spent months fine
tuning your top of the line intel mac
but now need to throw it in the garbage
because the new mac mini with an m1 chip
will blow it out of the water are you
going to reinstall and reconfigure
everything from scratch
hopefully not dot files are those little
hidden files on your system that start
with a period
like bashprofile.env or git config
just to name a few with a repository of
these files you can chronicle the
installation of your favorite
applications and command line tools
keep track of how all that software is
configured and record all the various
system preferences
and changes that you've made to your
computer these files already live on
your system and when you harness their
power you can replicate your perfect
development
environment on a new computer in a
completely hands-off and automated way
to get started you'll want to organize
all of your configuration files in a git
repository
that will allow you to track changes and
clone the repo on other machines
its code will contain at least one
script that applies or installs the
configurations on a new system
and that means weeks of hard manual
labor can be reduced down to a git clone
followed by an install script
maintaining your own dot files repo will
help you develop discipline for other
important skills
from command line use to get to the
organization
and inner workings of your machine wax
on
wax off read if you're ready to learn
more and build your own dot files repo
stay tuned today we're going
beyond 100 seconds with special guest
patrick mcdonald he's the instructor of
a full dot files course
and will teach you how to set up your
own dot files repo step by step
taking your developer productivity to
the next level youtube
meet patrick over the last 20 plus years
i've set up enough computers to have
acquired an appreciation of automating
that process
and i've gathered a few tricks i'd like
to share with you hello everyone
i'm patrick and i'll be your guide as we
go beyond 100 seconds
to learn how to back up a few typical
dot files
without disturbing your computer's
ability to use those files to configure
software
if you've never heard of dot files
you're probably familiar with a home
directory that looks like this
but as jeff mentioned mac os is littered
with hidden files
vs code is open to the same home
directory and its file explorer
shows several more items we can tell
finder to show the same hidden files by
entering the key combination command
shift period
most hidden files have a dot prefix
hence the name
dot files they can be folders as well as
files
and in special cases they can be hidden
by the operating system
even though they are missing the dot
that's all we need to know about
finder so let's look at vs code where we
can see
that our system uses dot files in our
home directory
software that comes pre-installed uses
hidden files too
and so does the custom software that we
install on our own
if you've been using your computer for a
significant amount of time
you likely have many more dot files here
we are going to focus on these two at
the bottom git config
and zshrc when you started using git
you probably issued a pair of commands
to set your name
and email address those settings ended
up here in the git config
file as you continue learning and using
git
this file can grow with more
configurations
before we move on let me recommend using
the no reply email address available
with your github account
when you publish your dot files repo for
the world to see
this lets you keep your personal email
address a secret
zsh is the new default shell on mac os
and the zshrc file is what you use to
customize the shell experience
so far we are only using this to
customize the prompt
but like we saw with the git config file
we can add to this file in many ways
we already have two files that are going
to change over time
what does this mean yes it means we're
going to need a git repository to start
tracking these files along with the
changes we make to them
let's open the integrated terminal where
we can see our super fancy custom prompt
in action
and where we can see that we start off
in the home directory
i've already set up a repository on
github so i'll start a git clone command
and paste in the ssh url now we need to
tell it the directory to create
and since everybody else is doing it
let's make a hidden folder by prefixing
our dot files repo
with a period our new directory has a
readme that we will look at shortly
but let's start by moving these two dot
files into the repo
so we can back them up of course the act
of moving them
isn't enough and these two files are
still untracked
so we will cd into the dot files
directory
where we can add the two files to the
repository and then we will commit them
but is this all we have to do will we be
done after entering this command
let's try it and it looks like we have a
problem
instead of using the user information
that we just saw in our git config
the output says that git automatically
configured
this committer information based on the
username and hostname
remember that software likes to use our
home directory
so by moving this file to a different
location we've broken the configuration
every time we make a commit git will
remind us of this problem
let's copy this suggested command about
resetting the author
and amending the commit and we will try
to fix this in a few minutes
what about our zsh configurations i
think we can assume that these are
broken as well
keep an eye on the file explorer to the
left as i kill this terminal
when a shell session ends its command
history is written out
and as software continues to add files
to our home directory
we have to decide whether to move these
files to our repository
zsh history is not the type of file we
want to track in our repo
so we will leave it here in the home
directory we just saw that zsh
writes to our home directory but it
tries to read from it as well
if we open a new shell we see that we've
lost our custom prompt
because zsh could not find the zshrc
file
instead we see the default prompt which
happens to have
a similar default to the one we just saw
for git using the same username and
hostname combination
how do we fix these broken
configurations we don't want to
duplicate these files
store their copies in the home directory
and manually keep them in sync
luckily there's a way that a file can be
in two places at the same time
which is called a symbolic link or
symlink for short
to create one we will use the ln or link
command
then we will add the s option which
stands for symbolic link
now we'll pass in the full path to the
real file in our dot files directory
and lastly we'll pass in the path to the
original location
where the zshrc file is expected to live
the file explorer now shows that the
zshrc file is back in the home directory
but it has an arrow to the right which
signifies that this is a sim link
if that arrow does not show up for you
reload the window and it should appear
now i'll kill the terminal again and
open the new
simlink version from the home directory
to the right of the zshrc
file in our dot files directory they
both look like normal files
don't they but if i add a comment to the
real file
and save it we can see that changes to
the real file at the left
will show up in the symlink version at
the right of course we can delete these
lines from the right
and after another save those changes are
reflected at the left
since vs code can follow the sim link to
the real file
and treat it as a real file i bet zsh
can too
if we open a new shell we see our custom
prompt has returned
when a shell loads it looks for the
zshrc file in the home directory
which follows the sim link to the real
file and
the customization makes it into the
shell not only did the shell load the
zshrc file
it also loaded the zsh history file
which is still in the home directory
this means we have access to previous
commands i can press
up to retrieve the most recent command
from the history
and then alter it to create a sim link
for the git config file
which we see appear in the explorer with
another arrow icon
we've seen enough of the home directory
so before testing our git config fix
let's open only the dot files directory
the key combo we used in finder to show
hidden files
command shift period works here as well
of course the arrows here on the file
icons
mean the same thing they do in the file
explorer after opening the dot files
directory we have less clutter to look
at
since we have the dot files directory
open in vs code
the integrated terminal will start at
the same location when we fire up a new
shell
a git log command will remind us that
our last commit has the wrong author
which happened because we moved the git
config file
we can check to see if our second sim
link is working
by checking the global git config for
the email address
which shows the correct no reply email
address that we saw before
now i'll paste in the command that i
copied a bit ago
if you issue this command as is you'll
end up editing the commit in vim
because it is the default editor and if
you're like me it will take you half an
hour to figure out how to exit them
changing the default editor perhaps to
nano or vs code
is the type of configuration you could
make to your git config
file and the change would be tracked in
your repo but in this case
we don't actually want to edit the
contents of the commit
so we can add the no edit option another
look at the git
log shows that the author information
has been corrected
we have successfully backed up our
configurations while preserving the
ability to use them
but that won't do a lot of good if our
software is not installed
we need an automated way of installing
software and for that we will use a
package manager called homebrew
it just so happens that i used homebrew
to install vs code along with some other
software
we don't have time to learn much about
it but homebrew keeps track of what it
has installed
and can output a list of software with
this command
after brew bundle dump i'll add the
describe option for a little more info
this command will create a file in your
current directory
so it's important that we are already in
our dot files repo
our new brew file has a list of software
that can be reinstalled at a later date
taps are the repositories where homebrew
keeps its own software
along with the information about the
other software it can install
brews are tools you typically use in
your shell
these top two are new tools i've added
to improve my shell experience
while these bottom two are upgraded
versions of pre-installed
software so homebrew helps keep
everything up to date
and the casks at the bottom are
full-blown applications that you
probably recognize
let's start one last shell add the brew
file to start tracking it
and do another commit note that this
time we did not get the warning message
that we saw before
about automatically configuring the
author that's another sign that our git
config sim link is working
so we will push our changes to the
remote repository
now we've saved our software along with
some configurations
but we haven't recorded the process when
the time comes to bootstrap a new
computer
using our dot files repository we are
likely to forget some steps
instead of researching and relearning
these things we can keep a list in the
readme
we haven't seen this first step yet
before we can use git
and homebrew we would need to install
the command line tools
after that we would clone the repository
to our new machine
ssh is preferred but you might want to
start with
https and switch remotes after you've
had a chance to set up ssh
with our configuration files on our
machine
we would then repeat our sim linking
steps you can probably see that this
would be unwieldy if we had a dozen sim
links
and the more manual steps we have the
more error prone our process
there are better ways to do this and
this is the type of thing you'd
eventually work into an install script
finally we would install homebrew and
then point it to our brew file to
reinstall
all of our software i really wish we had
the time to see this step in action
because it is very satisfying
just like we saw in the git config and
zshrc files
here we have another list of ideas
regarding improving our dot files
process
we haven't looked at saving system
preferences organizing this repo
into separate files building that
install script
or automating any of the steps we did
there are 11 billion possibilities which
we can't cover in 10 minutes
let alone 100 seconds but as jeff
mentioned i have a growing
course that thoroughly covers this
material and
for the next 30 days i'll keep the price
as low as the course platform allows
enroll now and your next computer setup
will be no match for your dot file
skills
thank you for watching and since there's
no way i could possibly thank jeff
enough for sharing his stage with me
please thank him on my behalf by liking
and sharing his videos
subscribing to this channel and going
pro
at fire ship io thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one